all right uh let's get right to it the
big news yesterday something that we saw
coming
as of last week although four weeks ago
panthers coach matt rule was trying to
sell a different reality about how
excited he was to coach cam newton that
was the last ditch effort i think to get
a team interested in trading for cam
newton act like you're going to keep him
maybe someone will come around and make
you a trade offer it ultimately was not
to be no trade partners available
especially because no team could bring
cam newton in for a physical so as we
both predicted chris the panthers cut
the cord on cam newton yesterday the
number one overall pick in the 2011
draft the 2015 league mvp
gone from carolina
a free agent for the first time in his
career able to sign with anyone
and oh my goodness the thought of having
that guy available and i know there's
this vague sense of what can he really
do because of the injuries but he
supposedly healed he passed a physical
now look he wants to pass that physical
and the panthers wanted to pass that
physical that's a panthers physical not
some other team
poking and prodding and making sure that
he's good to go but still as far as the
panthers are concerned as far as he's
concerned he's healthy he's available
and now we wait to see
who makes a run at him i wasn't
surprised by it chris but it still is
there's something that's just jarring
just as jarring as it is to see tom
brady signing with the buccaneers it's
jarring to see the panthers cutting cam
newton yeah it definitely is i mean he's
uh you could argue he's the the most
famous player to play in that franchise
history i know there's been some other
good ones there but you know certainly
the most notable quarterback one of the
freakiest specimens we've ever seen at
the quarterback position or in the nfl
at all he's a game changer i mean that's
why you didn't expect him to be on a
different team he was the number one
pick of the draft the heisman he's built
like a defensive end you know we see
what lamar jackson and these running
quarterbacks that we have right now and
football can do uh to defenses well cam
newton was a little ahead of his time
you know no he wasn't the runner lamar
jackson was but you could orchestrate an
offense around him that was very
different that's very stressful on
defenses and that's where his real value
is and if he's healthy he's still going
to be able to supply that for some
organization
yeah with cam newton the design runs
happened in short yardage in goal line
situations a lot of his more spectacular
long runs happened when the play broke
down and he off he went and he was gone
and you know he had some iconic and
memorable plays we're gonna have a draft
coming up in a about an hour and a half
of our most memorable cam newton moments
with the carolina panthers but you know
he he was a guy who when you got down to
the one when you got to third or fourth
and short he's so big you just have him
go forward and uh frankly i think the
fact that he looked so indestructible it
caused maybe both him and the panthers
to view him as indestructible and over
time the reality is he was destructed
whether it was a shoulder an ankle a
foot that's the problem because he
looked like a giant and was a giant i
think they they threw caution to the
wind a little too often and it's those
injuries that ultimately fueled his exit
from carolina chris
yeah it is they piled up and yeah i mean
yeah he's built like superman there's a
reason he does that little you know
pulls his shirt back to act like he's
showing his symbol
yeah they they used him and abused them
in a lot of ways and you said it was
short yardage situations it was second
and three and we're going to pull the
guard and have the full back and tail
back lead up the hole and cam newton's
going to be behind them and he's taking
on middle linebackers and putting his
head down and shoulder down and driving
for extra yards you know we talk about
tom brady being like the the king of the
quarterback sneak well k if you look at
the numbers cam newton's short yardage
runs blow that away that just tells you
how many times he's taken some of those
hits but the other thing too mike you
know i know we talk about the physical
specimen you know the guy can still
throw the football i mean you know when
healthy it's a top-tier arm
i mean he can push the ball down the
field now listen is he drew brees is he
gonna surgically dissect you with five
and six yard passes no
but the beauty of him is he doesn't need
to be that guy he can run the ball three
times in a row and then you know that
fourth play he can drop back and throw a
20-yard missile out route to a receiver
and and there you go as an offense so
that's the danger of cam newton he makes
teams defend the whole field and then
because of the ability to run
he makes defenses play defenses they
don't want to play which a lot of times
leads is the lamar jackson effect where
then you have to play some simple
defensive scheme because you're worried
if they do some crazy quarterback run or
some crazy design play that oh if we
blitz or play something crazy we can get
gashed here so it makes defensive
coordinators play very simple that way
and that's another great advantage
that's not going to be on the stat sheet
that cam newton brings to a football
team
before the panthers made the move to cut
cam newton they reportedly had some
discussions with both the bears and the
chargers i was told last week the
chargers were engaged in a debate
internally as to whether they should
pursue cam newton but they recognized
the difficulties of making a trade
happen because of the fact that the
covet 19 procedures prevent teams from
bringing players to the facility for an
appropriate physical look it's one thing
and i mentioned this a minute ago but i
need to i need to make sure that we're
all on the same page here yeah cam
newton passed a physical on monday
that was conducted by a doctor that the
panthers found in atlanta where cam
newton currently is well newton wants to
pass that physical and the panthers
wanted to pass that physical they want
to clear the decks they don't want to
release him with a failed physical
designation and maybe owe him money
later this year they want to set the
stage for him to land somewhere else he
wants to set the stage to land somewhere
else so that doesn't mean clean bill of
health that doesn't mean that the
chargers or any other team that would
pursue him will look at him and say he's
fine he passes our physical he can pass
the exit physical in carolina and fail
the entrance physical somewhere else so
don't make yourself conclude that that
it's just automatic that someone's going
to jump on him now chris obviously and
you've lived that life you know how
these doctors are i mean i don't want to
i don't want to cast aspersions here but
the doctors ultimately are bought and
paid for by the team they tend to come
to the conclusion the team wants them to
come to when it's time to uh administer
that physical
there's no question mike i mean you're
spot on yeah the team doesn't want you
oh the doctor you know you might be a
little banged up hey looks good you're
healthy yep he passed the physical we
can we can cut that guy and we don't
have to pay him a dollar he's healthy
then you go to another team and of
course they're about to invest money
into you like you're just saying and now
the physical examination goes up to
another level of you know detail and the
prodding and pulling and testing of
joints and you know the the mris all
that to where yeah now it's a it's
certainly a more in-depth screening
altogether and yes you might not pass
that and it's going to be big for cam
newton i mean we know the two injuries
he had the last two years i mean they're
serious
there's no doubt and now it looks like
the shoulder was good to go so hopefully
that's you know done with and teams
don't have to worry about that but liz
frank yeah you're gonna have to do your
due diligence on an injury like that for
a 250 pound quarterback who likes to run
and stick his foot in the ground and
take on middle linebackers and drive
them back and move and throw on the run
you definitely need to make sure that
you have the right people to evaluate
that foot to make sure it's structurally
strong nothing's going to happen and and
we can go all systems go going forward
i got another question for you but
before we get to that when we do the
close-up shot of you i see it more
clearly what's over your right shoulder
it looks like an unmade bed
oh no it's probably the couch and i just
pushed down some of the pillows i just
didn't want some of the pillows stick up
so i pushed i pushed them down a little
bit so they weren't in the shot
is that the couch you get sent to to
sleep on when you've been a pain in the
butt for your wife
no actually when my wife who can snore a
little sometimes i send her out here on
this thing right here
yeah
so um she's been really good lately i
haven't had to do it but during the
season i had to send her out here a few
times and she slept out yeah
it's good she's not sleeping out there
during the show although she wouldn't be
sleeping for long between you and me and
the chickens clucking she'd be up by now
the cam newton shoulder injury remember
last year all that talk about the new
throwing motion that seems like 10 years
ago with everything that's happened but
isn't that a concern also is the guy
really able to throw the ball
differently is he effective we didn't
see it he was gone after week two
remember that thursday night game i mean
he played two games in four days they
lost at home to the rams and then on
thursday night against the buccaneers he
looked awful and we didn't know at the
time they were lying to us about that
foot the foot was still messed up so you
really don't have a lot of film you can
look to from 2019 to come to any
conclusion about where cam newton is all
the more reason to bring him in not just
for a physical but for a workout to see
how he throws the ball to see how he
moves and that may delay this process
for as indefinitely as covet 19 is
delaying life for these teams and for
everyone else
yeah no i mean you're right you know we
we didn't get to see a lot of it and
remember he played up in new england
right in that preseason game and then he
rolled his ankle or hurt his foot there
too so we never got to see preseason
action yes we never really got to see
that new throwing motion he talked about
you know unveiled well we saw it and
what it really was is he went back to
his old throwing motion and there's no
there's no issue with that you know
listen he does a lot of good things
throwing the football he puts a lot of
stress on his arm sometimes with the way
he does it but i think you know if there
was real concern about the shoulder i
think you would have heard that and
those lead up to that week one week two
game even late in the preseason where
they would have said man cam you know
rumors would have got out cam newton's
arm's not the same he's lost some pep or
he can only throw so many balls into
practice and then he dies out you know i
didn't hear any of that stuff and you
know i i would think by just what i saw
he's good to go in the shoulder
department but your point still stands
mike if i'm a team that's about to throw
20 million dollars or more at him i want
to work him out watch him throw make
sure that he can really let it go and
that there is no uh nothing holding him
back or structural damage that might be
you know hindering his ability to throw
at a high level
and you know it's possible that we
didn't hear much
about any internal fretting over cam
newton's shoulder as the regular season
approached because it was that seemingly
innocuous foot injury against the
patriots that became the liz frank
problem that ultimately ended his season
after the first four days of it week one
sunday week two thursday night never to
be seen again in a panthers uniform i
mean in hindsight think about that did
any of us have any idea that that was
the last time we'd ever see cam newton
in a panthers uniform i remember how bad
he looked that night and i remember
thinking if this guy isn't injured then
he's just done he's just lost it the
good news was that he was injured
because at least provides an explanation
for why he was so bad that night against
the tampa bay buccaneer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports